We started off by talking about energy and that complete one-for-one
relationship between the size of the economy and the amount of energy
generated. So let's check back in. Look
what's happened happening since 1970.
Here's where we were with energy use up until the first Earth Day. Here's what's
been happening in the years since. We are decoupling—profoundly—the growth of our
economy, the growth of our society, and our prosperity, from the total amount of
joules, or BTUs, that you need to generate that economy. Our economy is about 25
percent bigger than it was at the end of
the Great Recession. Our energy use is
essentially flat all throughout that
time. The added good news here is that
largely because of the fracking revolution, where we're burning less coal
and using more natural gas to generate electricity,
our total greenhouse gas emissions are
actually now trending downward over time.
And that red line is really interesting;
it comes from a data source that takes
into account the carbon generated by all
the products that we import. So this
really is the accurate picture of the
carbon footprint of the American economy.
And I think it is past its peak, it's
trending down, and I will take anyone's
bet that we're not going to hit that high point ever again—or at least for
the next ten years. Now, I want to say
this really clearly: this line is not
going down quickly enough. I am NOT
encouraging any kind of complacency here.
But we have finally decoupled growing
our economy from generating greenhouse
gases in a pretty deep way.